50 meter weiter lassen durch bildung auf
mittlerweile dass in allen worten ist
das lustig niemand wird ihm und an lebt
hier mit basel weiter kommen wir haben
im hintergrund jetzt neues accessoire
gut oder kann man immer was rein freien
hatte glück richtung gewürze wir hätten
einen geburtstag vergessen aber nur um
mein tag ich habe es ja nicht ganz
vergessen aber das ist mir nicht
passieren mehr halt öfter so ich bin
echt menschlich kommen nicht also ich
bin halt irgendwie da so ein bisschen
man muss sich aber auch man kann sich
doch nicht von allen seiten sollen
geburtstagen ja dafür erst mal ein
daumen runter und damit sollte was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video und um was gehts heute nun
wäre es schon erwarten sind mann kannst
du nicht lesen das fehlt im busch und
zwar habe ich vor einer woche bereits
hochgeladen ich testete zehn weitere
neue kostenlose produkte das semi
komischerweise ein bisschen
untergegangen
allerdings habe ich noch ganz viele
andere kostenlose produkte bestellt mich
auch noch auspacken
das soll mein tabak sorry soll ich das
rein schneider
okay das gehört jetzt nicht dazu das war
jurist aber auf jeden fall haben wir
hier zehn wirklich geile sachen alles
kostenlos beim letzten part war es ein
bisschen so dass es ein bisschen
madelaine war so weil die sachen halt
scheiße waren zum großen teil
heute haben wir die besseren sachen
dabei deswegen freut sich aufs video
lehnt euch zurück und ich würde sagen
wir müssen uns erst mal was ein antikes
video oder oder was sagst du dazu
ich komme gleich wieder ich bin gleich
wieder lachen krass oder sichersten
solche fischermann die machen einfach so
ein kostenloses frühstück und also klar
die qualitäts grausam aber ich hatte
sogar mal die idee selber halt so police
zu machen halt in guter qualität auf der
welt geben
[Musik]
das musste jetzt immer einmal wieder das
riecht das ist halt schon ein bisschen
gefährlich
das riecht so grausam
ich denke schon zu über alle möchten
rosen hängen gegen welche aus mit wird
gut brauchen
es musste also mach weiter nächstes
[Applaus]
genau ich habe bluetooth cockpit die
waren halt echt kostenlos so und so gibt
es dann bei real für 12 euro der ja mach
ich das irgendwie falsch ist denn ihr
könnt mich nicht mehr helfen
du kannst mir in merzen das verstehe ich
heute macht alle genau jetzt noch
screenshot dann passt das auf instagram
okay ja gut soll ich jetzt zuerst die
soundqualität hast und was machen wir
dann mit rechts links sind scheiße und
wie ich lasse nicht über meine oma war
ich noch mal ganz kurzen test gegner mit
70 47 machten fotos die qualität ist
ungefähr so wie bei diesen drei euro
oder gar nicht mehr grad von jugend
getestet haben aber dann bestell doch
wieder hier diese hier kostenlos ich
mache auch scheiße ok kommen wir zum
nächsten produkt das man das handy wenn
dieses video 8000 likes macht habe ich
immer jetzt das richtschwert anderem mit
video soll ich mir bestellt
eigentlich sind das leds aber niemanden
anstecken
das tut mir echt leid was macht man da
jetzt können wir nichts machen also also
es gibt auf jeden fall diese led stripes
die man dann halt irgendwie konnten muss
aber wir haben jetzt in unserem fall
leider keinen passenden adapter hierfür
obwohl warte mal kann man das nicht
damit connecten mit diesen dingern dass
sie den 62 kabel die muss sehr gut gut
dann hat sich das erledigt aber kein
grund zur aufregung wir haben ja noch
sieben weitere sachen ja endlich wieder
sagen weißt du hast das problem ist ich
war schon fast monatlich für bei meinen
eltern
und obwohl das war ein bisschen
unangenehm das jetzt zu sagen
aber hier in köln gehalten die selber
meine wäsche deswegen habe ich gerade
auch keinen job mehr und kann die jetzt
um so besser gebrauchen
gute qualität eigentlich also wir haben
hier in der tat socken und weißt du was
unten draufsteht was man auch kostenlos
man stellte stelle meine fragen alles
klar
die gibt es hier auch weißt du was das
muss ich auch dahin ein fakt ist ja wir
sind auch gute sachen oder ich hab ja
nicht aus versehen meine letzten
kostenlosen richten verloren und da muss
man halt mal neue jahr und für diese
hier nicht entschieden
kommen wir zum nächsten produkt also
socken immer etwas sehr nice es so gibt
es auch halt da manchmal umsonst fand er
soll aber die sind cool
die sind echt geil sänger genau da kann
ich mich alter krass ey ich habe solche
geile sachen bestellt können wir fand am
pentagon dass sie voll geil aus mit dem
blauen t shirt und dem orangen socken
endlich wieder socken und wer hat mir
zuhause fand
[Musik]
ich weiß die somit angeblich heute reste
bei manchen fällen sich dann vielleicht
auch weil ich so cool sachen ab und wie
man leute die das video schauen wollt
dann kann ich mal nicht so weiß selbst
komme ich zum nächsten verlust also das
jetzt bin ich wirklich schon richtig
begeistert dass es eigentlich kann man
sagen mein lieblings zehn kostenlose
produkt gefragt und es ist jetzt schon
der sechste mittlerweile das ist schon
so lange her ich kann mich gar nicht
mehr richtig daran erinnern was ich
damals alles bestellt habe wir haben
hier kostenlose kopfhörer ich blende
euch hier auch immer das produkt ein
einfach also warten wir sehen auf jeden
fall aus wie die von apple so auf den
ersten blick sehr gut aber der ton kann
ja eigentlich nicht geil sein
[Musik]
pastor denkt allerdings geht nicht mal
gute kommen kann man direkt in möglich
meisten sonnenschein
okay wir haben ein bisschen chaos ich
habe gar kein fan ich musste erst mal
versuchen kommt jetzt erst mal das grüne
ok viele sachen haben wir auch was man
jemals starten
[Applaus]
was war das denn ich glaube das war
glaube ich wahrscheinlich gedacht und
was ist das denn und das sag mal so groß
auf dem foto weil das hat ja da hast du
damit anfangen leute sollten gut dass
das komme aus weiter geht's johanne
lichterkette fast ausverkauft da kann
ich mir auch genau vorstellen wie das
auf dem produktfoto aussieht ich glaube
ich weiß es nämlich noch da ist jetzt
ein geländer und da ist diese herum
gewickelt jetzt so richtig schön und
dann kommt hier als sowas an moment das
rad oder eine lichterkette ok oh weißt
du was da können wir den tannenbaum
schmücken keine tollen ball aber
eigentlich ganz mehr als oder ich mein
pfad ist es werden kann man sich dann
aber doch weniger also hier werdet ihr
noch funktioniert ist so zwei drei meter
lang
was vielleicht ist immer für die videos
mit wackelkontakt du bist halt richtig
an die wand machen um das bild vom oder
zum beispiel dass man erst mal einen
beliebigen nicht immer lecker was fürs
nächste video deswegen unbedingt wieder
einschalten
wir nahmen 19 uhr sein neues buch okay
wir haben allerdings noch ein paar
produkte die jetzt natürlich noch
ausgepackt werden müssen zwei sachen
wird sagt das habe ich vergessen das war
das heute noch so nah ist out produkten
der kompost der heißt auskommen dritte
art hier vollständig lied eigentlich
gern auch so als kette kommt natürlich
um längen nicht an meine gedanken daran
das ist ganz klar also die geänderte
leute das ist eigentlich ein video was
ihr euch auch geben ist ich teste die
besten eyes out produkte von wick kam
auch schon vor zwei drei wochen ich
verlinke am ende steckt das auf jeden
fall noch ab weiß es noch nicht gesehen
habt denn willkommen hier jetzt leider
schon zum letzten produkt
ist das netzwerk das ist nett das ist
für über 3 war in china damit die
kommunizieren können
doch alles und denken drinnen und 8 das
habe ich jetzt immer drin weil im video
das okay herzlich willkommen sind
verbunden mit der rückschau auf zentrale
am apparat alex wie was kann ich für sie
tun ja ok ja dann schicke ich ihnen als
wiedergutmachung den zehn prozent rabatt
anbieten
der lautet v1 einfach mal ausprobieren
sogar vielen dank ich hoffe ich über den
helfen auch wieder war es den korb gibt
es halt wirklich schön aber ich mache ja
echt werbung also das ist ja schon das
ist ja eigentlich ist es ja heute fast
ein werbevideo leute wären hätte
brauchen dann muss ich halt mich extra
testen dann bestellt euch meinetwegen
allerdings war ich zu bezweifeln dass es
keine gute qualität hat
hier werden du wirst eigentlich mal
bezahlt von wohlstand auch nicht leute
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen
doch nach oben da wir sehen uns morgen
19 uhr wieder gibt's neues video morgen
einen essens video glaube ich damit den
kanal aktive die leute auf instagram hat
sich alex wie und ja wir sehen uns haut
rein